it all happened so fast I didn't know  what to do  the explosion flashed throw from the  halt I'm drifting with limited power and  no control flying completely blind does  anyone copy  I can hear you who is this this is ha 18  Hathor 18 good ok huh Who am I speaking  to  I just don't have any coordinates hey  but I don't have any coordinates  commander  how about space that's what I see a  departure from Dec has propelled you  straight for the Sun coming for you  [Music]  I need you to call home to tell her I'm  sorry Kevin window crack being able to  intercept you before significant  radiation exposure but it's not gonna  work we going too fast this lifeboat has  no airlock the propulsion and thruster  systems are down sure in all control  cares about right now is there an  insurance policy  [Music]  don't you ever go  [Applause]  you  you